yo creo que afa rodolfo fernández lo
favoreció 22 circunstancias la primera
la baja afiliación política que en este
momento tiene los jóvenes una baja
afiliación política también que tienen
muchos ciudadanos en colombia la
desafección política que tienen hacia
los partidos políticos la mayoría de los
ciudadanos y el a mostrarse como un
candidato completamente anti partido
político de monuc sider político pues
allí encontró un gran caudal electoral
por otra parte hay que reconocer la gran
campaña electoral que hizo en materia de
red es muy similar tal vez a la que hizo
en ecuador lazo que a partir de redes
sociales tick tock twitter facebook
aumentos o caudal electoral de manera
exorbitante y en este caso yo creo que
la gran
el gran caudal electoral que también en
este momento está recogiendo roedor
fernández es un grupo de jóvenes que se
informan por redes sociales que lo ven
como un candidato completamente anti
corrupto completamente contra la
corrupción fresco que le hablan en el
lenguaje que los jóvenes quieren hablar
que es una persona simpática que es una
persona empática yo creo que en una
ciudadanía donde tiene una gran
desconfianza en los partidos políticos
donde muchos jóvenes no tienen afinidad
política o no tienen afiliación política
más el manejo de redes que se ha hecho a
partir de sus estrategias de campaña
pues fueron los dos digamos los dos
elementos que hicieron que rodolfo
hernández repuntará en las últimas
semanas